I remember going to a show of a very
famous comedians 3000 C theater in
Boston and the comedian was just this
tall in a little spotlight and I'm in
the back and I'm going like what is this
like I should just be listening to this
on a CD or something but I thought like
if I can ever get to a point where I
could play theatres I'm gonna use this
space I'm gonna use look look at those
look at her rig up there I mean look at
this thing like this place could be
bumpin it's theater
it really is theater okay get some mood
lighting please just perfect I don't
feel at home in the world of stand-up I
like the people in it but like when I go
to a comedy club I'd be like what is
like this place is not for me it was
always sort of trying to wrestle the
things I loved about theater into
stand-up which was you know staging and
lighting and things like that
[Music]
just go to a venue and okay have an idea
that I want to black out in a spotlight
here so I have to sort of wrestle the
show technically every night given what
was in the space we were all right the
microphone was the one that works I
wanted to build a show and write the
show
for the space of a theatre a show that
couldn't be done in the smaller space
writing the bits wid the lighting in
mind all right now right brain you're
being insane no left brain
I'm just being alive and that bit was
really like I saw David Hasselhoff a
performance of him doing Jekyll and Hyde
the musical and it's him being like come
on and it's all these lights match isn't
it was just beautiful you see stand up
in 3000 see Peters you see them in
arenas and it's the exact same thing
that we've done in a comedy club had
just blown up and you go to arena shows
and you're like just watching a guy talk
and you're just watching the television
it's like man this forum is like
limitless yeah it's put into such a
silly silly box the whole point was like
we're gonna work on the technical
aspects of the show and the jokes all at
the same time we're gonna test this show
on the road as a technical thing in
1,500 C theatres we spent two weeks in a
little garage with the full lighting
setup before the show after the show we
would sit down and go okay that luck
that didn't totally work we would change
lighting cues we would you know test the
lighting hue like a Joe
the other day the other thing was you
introduced some film language and you
actually do it like a movie and not just
like a taped performance there are
pickups all over the show the country
song there's the dolly thing that goes
on the front of the stage if you pay
attention you realize well the camera
can't be there the big sort of push
crane push when all the lights come down
and I go down there is a minute and a
half of that last bit this film without
an audience I went to Kanye West's
recent toward the yeezus tour it was a
big dramatic theatrical show I have
always been a fan of him deeply
conceptually I think he is an incredible
approach to the theatricality of live
performance and arena performance he
tackles arena performance in a way no
one else does he it's a really really
economic use of lighting monochromatic
lighting to st. Pablo toward this last
one I directed Chris Rock's last special
ripped off that really is
it's just ripping off the Saint Pablo
monochromatic sort of incandescent light
for that there's also you know factors
in it that are just very unique to what
it is which is lighting specifically
lighting an audio-visual are they
specials visually are it's a very low
bar to clear to be better than the
average one every stand-up special looks
to me like Conan live from the Chicago
Theatre you get to a taping of a special
and it's all this production put on to a
hour of comedy that's never been like
that yeah I mean it's purple lights and
all this stupid shit and it's like it
makes no sense we made sure odd
Carmichael's special one thing I want to
do is try to make it an especially those
alive cinematically you know like we're
the camera movement and the angles for
the texture of the light and the shadows
meant something that the way the
audience was lit meant something the way
that was shot meant something what I
liked about it was you know there's a
very lonely experience for me out there
that's what it feels like it feels like
lonely and anxious and it feels like a
silly version of what I feel like a lot
of people go through
hey guys
Kayla back here with another video the
movies about Kayla a 13 year old girl in
her last week of eighth grade me my DPB
tested before we even had money for the
movie like how do we film screens
practically we'd wanted to film them
practically for me the stupid thing is
like I hate like when people are
tweeting in movies and the tweet like
shows up superimposed and that's when it
gets like corny and weird to me and like
a close-up of a shattered phone to me
looks like gorgeous you know it looks
like very interesting and cool it was
all interesting to me and significant to
me I think probably it's unsetting to
people that maybe don't view it
emotionally when you see people my age
and younger that's are gonna start to be
able to express themselves in the film
or other mediums I think you'll start to
see the internet talked about more
emotionally and personally Barry Lyndon
writing a letter by Candlelight s' the
most cinematic thing in the world but
like a girl on her phone in the dark
which literally is the candle and the
letter are fused she's got the cold
light on her the cold white light of her
phone and he's always in the doorway
with the warm light of that which is
then sort of the warm light in the
dining room table which is the same as
this sort of light of the fire I mean I
found it always cinematic I didn't
really understand this oh sure phobia
for it like it's a light source I don't
think you can be too proud of the
special it's amazing oh that's that's
nice
yeah I think it looks cool I can vouch
for it on mute fully I can show you
someone on mute and be like I mean this
is exactly how I pictured it on mute I
think it looks cool
[Music]
[Laughter]
one of the many cool aspects of Bose
creative process is how he constantly
uses the Internet to learn and develop
his own ideas he got inspiration on
writing Kayla's vlog by watching young
people talk about similar topics on
YouTube the internet is full of
inspiration to help you with your
creative projects if you want to be like
Bo and improve the lighting of your
videos you can start by signing up for a
class about studio lighting on
Skillshare Skillshare has over 20,000
classes on a wide array of topics from
business to filmmaking join the millions
of people already learning on Skillshare
today with this special offer click on
the link in the description below to get
two months completely free that's the
class on studio lighting plus thousands
of others ranging from creative writing
to marketing and design thanks for
watching and a big thanks to Skillshare
for sponsoring this video
[Music]